quick reminder that we have more
detailed maps of the surface of Mars
than the Earth's ocean floor in fact
there's a map for that this is a map
that highlights in dark blue what part
of the ocean floor is still unmapped it
also shows the percentage of unmapped
territory on the shores of different
countries Japan's doing pretty good
they've mapped most of their ocean floor
while Thailand has barely mapped any of
their Ocean and the U.S still has about
a third of its oceans unmapped the ocean
makes up like 70 percent of the Earth's
surface so why don't we have a good map
of like the majority of our planet it
comes down to a lack of will it's not
like it's crazy expensive it would cost
an estimated three billion dollars to
create a detailed map of the entire
ocean floor that's like a rounding error
for like the US military or Jeff Bezos
NASA spent around that much three
billion dollars to send the perseverance
Rover to Mars billions more on previous
Mars missions which I get it that's
really useful fascinating stuff but
wouldn't it be equally so to discover
what our own planet looks like